covid and flu are not the only viruses
to look out for in your children
hospitals across the country are seeing
a spike in patients with RSV that's an
acronym we'll get to the meaning it's a
respiratory illness that hospitalizes
nearly 60 000 children every year under
the age of five CBS News contributor Dr
Celine gounder is here with what you
need to know she's an epidemiologist an
editor at large at kff's Kaiser health
news uh Dr gounder thank you for being
here uh RSV what does it stand for what
is it respiratory Sensational virus RSV
so this is another one of these cold
viruses kind of like covet in the flu
can infect your upper respiratory Airway
so that would be the nose the throat in
that case that causes a runny stuffy
nose a cough sore throat but when it
gets into the lower airway so the
bronchi the lungs in little kids that
causes bronchiolitis pneumonia that can
be a lot more dangerous why does it
affect little kids and how do they get
it well when little kids get it
especially infants they don't have
mature immune systems so they're not
able to fight it off as well and they
have much smaller Airways so when you
get inflammation in the Airways they get
thicker when you get mucus you get
plugging so they just run into trouble a
lot more easily but how do they get it
though that's it's just one of those
things it's one of these viral
respiratory infections so it's through
the air through droplets just like you
might get covet or the flu how do we
recognize it what are the ones What's So
Scary About young kids is that they're
very noisy breathers in general yeah
we're doing some work in the house right
now so Eloise is back in our room and
she's doesn't have RSV as far as we know
but we don't know if it's off or a
running nose it's like Grandma snoring
in the Next Room yeah you're right that
loud and sometimes you ignore it as a
parent because it seems normal so when
when does the normal noisy breathing of
an infant become problematic well so if
the baby's not feeding as well if the
baby's irritable and then there are
certain respiratory signs that you would
really worry about so if they're gasping
if they're wheezing if they're coughing
so much they can't really get a good
breath of air I would really start to
get worried at that point why are we
seeing an increase now as I had never
heard of RSV before well I think a lot
of parents of little kids will be
familiar and then the elderly also get
pretty severe RSV the reason we're
seeing a big surge now is during the
pandemic we were masking we were social
distancing and so you have all these
little kids that were never exposed and
they're all getting exposed all at once
so what should a parent do if if they
see symptoms well there's no way to know
is this RSV is this covet is this the
flu without a test and so just like for
covid we have the PCR test we have the
antigen test which are the ones that you
use at home we have similar tests for
RSV the only thing those you know we
have those at-home tests for covid yeah
they don't exist the at-home tests don't
exist for RSV that would be a really
nice tool for parents to have
unfortunately right now you do have to
go into a pediatrician you just
recommend going in if you have those
yeah if you have those warning signs I
would definitely go in and get your
child do they test them through the nose
or is it a blood test it'll be through
the nose yeah you would get a swab just
like for just like the flu yeah all
right the hits keep coming doesn't it I
know it never ends no it's not one thing
it's the other thing or the other thing
yeah Dr sling calendar thank you so much